you mentioned
briefly that stock markets are good from
my sort of outside
perspective is there a sense
do you think trading stocks is uh
closer to gambling or is it closer to
investing
sometimes it feels like it's gambling
uh as opposed to betting on companies to
succeed and this is maybe connected to
our discussion of shorting in general
but
like from your sense the way you think
about it is it fundamentally still
investing
i do think um i mean it's a good
question it i
it's i've also seen lately people say
this is like speculation is there too
much speculation in the market and it's
like
but all the trades are speculative like
all the trades have a horizon
like people want them to work um
uh so i i i would say that
um and there's certainly a lot of
aspects of
gambling uh math that applies to
investing okay
like one thing you don't do in gambling
is put all your money in one
bet you have bankroll management and
it's a key part of it
and small alterations to your bank role
management
might be better than improvements to
your skill
um so there and then there are things we
care about in our fund like we want to
make a lot of independent
bets we talk about it like we want to
make a lot of independent bets because
that's going to be um
a higher sharp than if you have a lot of
bets that depend on each other like all
in one sector
um but but yeah i mean the point the
the point is that you want the prices of
the stocks to be
to be reflective of of how
of their value of the underlying value
yeah yeah you shouldn't have
there be like a hedge fund that's able
to say well
um i've looked at some data and all of
this stuff's super mispriced
like that's super bad for society if
it's if it looks like that to someone
i guess the the underlying question then
is uh
do you see that the market often like
drifts away
from the underlying value of companies
and it becomes a game in itself
like with these whatever they're called
like derivatives like
the option like you know um
options and uh shorting and all that
kind of stuff
it's like layers of game on top of the
actual like what you said which is like
the basic thing that the wall street
bets was doing which is like just buying
stocks
yeah there are a lot of uh games that
people play that
are um in the derivatives market and
i think a lot of the stuff people
dislike when they look at the history of
of what's happened they hate like credit
default swaps
or collateralized debt obligations like
these are the
these are the kind of like enemies of
and then the long-term capital
management thing it was like
it was like that 30 times leverage or so
or something just that
no one like you could just go to um a
gas station
and ask anybody at the gas station is it
a good idea to have 30 times leverage
and they just say no
the common sense just like went out the
window so
the i yeah i don't i don't
i don't respect long-term capital
management
[Laughter]
okay but numero doesn't actually use any
derivatives
unless you call shorting derivative uh
we just we do put money into companies
we and that does help the companies
we're investing in it's just in little
ways
um we we really did buy tesla and it and
it did
and we were you know we were not um we
played some role in in that's it's
success
super small make no mistake but still i
think that's important
you